thank you for joining council of geeks
i'm joined by paul scavito and ryan daly
and this time we're going to talk about
the sort of one two three punch of
teaser trailers that we had for some of
the big movies that are coming out next
year so if we're going with the order
that the trailers came out i guess we
start with jurassic world which i sort
of did my own solo random so i won't get
into my nitpicks about it but sort of
the recurring theme for me with actually
all three of these a franchise that is
tainted
i'm never gonna be turned around by the
marketing i feel like other people got
way more excited than i did and i'm
almost kind of jealous because i'm like
i'm a jaded bastard because i can't
allow myself to get that excited because
i've had i've had the crash i i think
the teaser for jurassic world is bad um
and
and i think it is because i think
there's a lot of dumb so but i have to
temper that with
i love dinosaurs
and i love kids in parks no you don't
you know i want to see this stuff um
but there's some really stupid things
i'm actually going to stop for a second
and give it to ryan so you don't think
any amount of marketing can change your
feeling on this i don't i don't think
the marketing can get me pumped okay so
i think the marketing is the only thing
that can get me into this movie
um because like you i i thought this
trailer did nothing for me in fact just
discouraged me from seeing this based on
that trailer i don't think this movie is
for me i don't think it's for our
generation that saw and grew up with the
original jurassic park movies i think
it's for
a younger generation that hasn't seen
those movies and doesn't want to watch
movies that are more than 10 years old
um just the dumb that's in it
i'm not going to say there isn't dumb in
yes i am going to say the only time
jurassic park has ever been smart was
the first time that's because there was
an inherent lesson to be learned right
from the first movie and the longer they
keep doing this they realize that these
characters aren't learning that lesson
they haven't learned anything so they
must be done and i
am kind of okay with the fact that they
have just doubled down on the dumb
as long as they can make it fun dumb i i
just want to just very briefly
deconstruct what the dumb is in the film
do i want to go to a park where i see
dinosaurs
yes
um do i want to get to them as close to
them as i possibly can yes
what would i expect the safety measures
to be in place at said park well i
expected to be pretty extreme if there's
an enormous um leviathan i don't know
that you necessarily would do the like
nose writing routine with it um get
seats in the splash though yeah and so
the the bubble is really the the boys in
the bubble is what breaks it for me
because
i don't care what the bubble's made out
of and actually the problem is they show
me the bubble being broken later right
so that tells me that that bubble was
not made of a destructo um plastic right
it's made of breakable plastic
apparently right and so the boys are
running along next to whatever that
giant dinosaur is um because they're no
longer called brontosaurus i don't think
it's apothecary
something is enormous right right at
best right they kind of get near him and
then it's okay but even if it poops on
them
right
they're going to be encased and they can
how long does it take another person to
get out there and shovel them out of the
dinosaur poop and like if it falls on
them or steps on them and
they're in the indestructible ball
they're trapped under an enormous
dinosaur and how long does it take to
move that so we need to address like the
reasoning the murder source on paper i'm
actually kind of okay with this and and
there there were rumors for a long time
that what
what jurassic park was going to be was
actually dinosaur dna crossed with
humans
that was the talk for a long time the
idea of them splicing into new
configurations was something i kind of
came to terms with about 10 years ago
when they were first batting around that
ridiculous notion the only way they can
save that premise for me it's created to
be a weapon that they have weaponized
dinosaurs that because that would be
different i haven't seen that except
except that makes no sense i mean that
the premise as i understand well it's
cost money
i think it's cheaper than engineering
you know a new lifeline i haven't
crunched the numbers but i don't think
but
well
the theory behind it is that
jurassic park or jurassic world or
whatever the theme park is called is
open and people have been coming and
they're kind of over the novelty of it
and
the numbers are declining so how do we
get people back we make a brand new
dinosaur is stupid
but
but it is that kind of corporate how do
we keep this money machine rolling
stupid that i could actually kind of
believe happened but you also have to
get me that's how we get the kfc double
down sandwich i know this is the kfc
doubled out of dinosaurs you have to
convince you have to already sell me on
the idea that the world's only dinosaur
park is unpopular
i want to see that i want to see
teenagers just standing there by
velociraptors
well actually which brings up the last
name which we haven't talked about which
is that last shot with him on the
motorcycles and there's been a lot of
rumor that he is actually somehow
trained and
velociraptors to if nothing else not
kill him that actually intrigues me and
i would like that idea because i
i would like to see these
treated more as animals
that can think and that can actually
reason that aren't just plot devices for
violence animals have certain behavior
and i would like to see them act like
animals and not like
the villain um so if they can do
something with that that that would at
least be something i haven't seen from
this film franchise i would love to
believe that that's what it is i don't
think it is i think what they're using
them for is remember how scary
velociraptors are right now they're
running away
well except i i think i think they may
just be smart enough not to do that
because nobody bought into the
spinosaurus in the third movie and they
did that exact thing remember how
awesome the t-rex was well it just got
its butt kicked isn't this more awesome
no no we like the t-rex we don't like
this thing so i think i think they may
have learned their lesson oh but i do
have a theory about what the super
murder source is which is the
tyrannosaurus rex with arms so okay so
moving along to the one that that really
got everybody's motor running which was
the star wars the force awakens trailer
i had no idea what to expect in terms of
the visual shots that we would get from
this teaser
but the teaser was still exactly what i
expected um it was going to
be provocative and it was going to ask
it was going to have the audience asking
a lot more questions than they get
answered from those images um and the
other thing that i expected
because this wasn't apparent in the
three star wars movies preceding this
one um was the sense of movement and the
sense of energy so i was really pleased
and intrigued by these things i liked
the opening shots we get a stormtrooper
who's obviously not a clone i like that
we're seeing a black man and a woman as
the first human figures that we see
um things that looked familiar but
different on the vehicles we see tie
fighters we see them on falcon we see
different versions of x-wings
i liked that we did not see
harrison ford mark campbell and carrie
i think that was really smart because
you got to sell us on these other people
right and because i don't want luke
skywalker han solo and princess leia to
be the main characters yes i don't want
the new adventures of old han solo um
but the droid the ball droid then i
think a lot of people went
don't like that it doesn't look
practical i didn't go
but it did take me a second to go
wait what did you see interstellar there
is a robot in interstellar that looks
stupid i grew to really like that robot
and it was used very very effectively
i've seen droids look dumber that were
used really
anyone who wants to call bs on that
droid i would immediately say i bet you
get the biggest grin on your face when
the little toaster droid
gets roared at by the wookie goes
right right you smile so big and you
love that so don't call bs on the ball
droid we've already had toaster droid
right the cinematic sort of look of
these of these films one of the things
and they're actually it was best um
highlighted i thought by
a fan made trailer which was the george
lucas special edition
and it just it it encapsulated
everything that i thought this got right
they're beautiful shots sure like
they're beautiful shots it's very clear
that we're on location
it's clear that the actors are
interacting with sets it's clear that we
have real props um that they're using
that their um their costumes are real
right um and there's
the scenes are not filled with crap that
we have to see in or around and what it
reminded me of is that opening shot of
the first film
you know how i mean go back to that shot
you know that how clean that shot is
that we're telling a story we've got a
little ship running away from the big
one right and we're getting
those of those early sort of images of
what the story is going to be about
right and i can say legitimately that i
am excited um about this movie based on
this teaser which brings us finally to
terminator genesis oddly and i didn't
expect this was actually the teaser that
got the most positive reaction out of me
versus the other two which in jurassic
world kind of made me
and in star the star wars i went okay
this actually did turn me around so i'm
still not gonna say i'm pumped for
terminator genesis but it kind of sold
me on the idea and i'm not no i'm now
not dismissing it out of hand when it
opens up giving us the war in the future
as we have come to know it this isn't
the terminator salvation version of the
war right and then to see them perfectly
recreating that alleyway and that store
and and then
they literally drove a truck through the
old continuity
and and but had her say that same line
come with me if you want to live i'm
like i'm i'm not just going to write
this off now you have my attention so
for me um did it get me excited no i
joked instantly that what i saw this was
it was ripping off x-men days of future
past
terminator 2.
i loved terminator and i really liked
terminator 2
and i was fine with those movies being
it like the universe it never felt like
as as much as like the glimpses of the
apocalyptic future and the war as much
as that looked cool
i never needed a movie about that i
never needed this franchise to keep
going they're doing this slightly softer
reboot but they're reintroducing these
characters and this older continuity
for a younger audience that isn't
familiar with it and if this introduces
a new generation of these characters i
hope they love it but that also feels
like an acknowledgement that
they're leaving me behind and i'm okay
with that the question you have to ask
is how many times can you tell this
story and they literally have answered
it by saying we can tell it one more
time um we can literally tell the exact
same story um that we've told before but
in a new interesting twisty time travel
way um but we really have been here i'm
intrigued by emilia clarke um because i
like her but i really just known her
from playing one character on game of
thrones and this that's all pretty much
anybody knows her from she she doesn't
have a long resume prior to doing
daenerys right and i want to see her
doing a very different character and
this certainly looks like that so
um
i don't know if this was just my
experience or if this was yours but did
it look like the title was there was a
typo i guess uh i guess that wraps it up
so that's the latest batch of teasers
and trailers and stuff that they're
trying to throw at us to get our money
they're filthy filthy that way in
any case thank you for joining us and
until next time this council is
adjourned
thank you for joining council of geeks i
am joined by paul dalian
let's try that again
that'll be the post credit stinger